DEREK DOWNEY: Hi, I'm Derek
Downey, a Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud.
I am excited to share some great
news if you are using Cloud
Spanner and have
downstream systems that
need to be aware of data
changes in near real time.
Getting data changes from
one system into another,
especially in real time,
can be challenging.
To address this,
Cloud Spanner just
released Change
Streams to make it
easy to set up pipelines
to process changes made
to your Spanner data.
In this video, I will explain
what change streams are
and what is required
to set them up.
Then I will show you how easy
it is to set up a change stream
and a pipeline to
process changes
made to your Spanner data into
a downstream BigQuery analytics
environment.
Finally, I'll go over some
typical use cases for change
streams and how Spanner makes it
easy to enable those use cases.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, what are change streams?
If you have ever heard of change
data capture, or CDC, that's
a good starting point
for understanding change
streams in Cloud Spanner.
Change streams keep
track of changes
made to data through DML or
Spanner mutations that can then
be processed by pipelines to
publish in a downstream system.
There are many
reasons you might want
to get data changes from
one system into another.
You might have a data
warehouse and you
need real time information to
improve business decisions.
You might want to trigger
downstream application
workflows, for instance,
restocking an item
if the inventory level
drops beneath a threshold.
You might have a need to keep
an audit trail of changes
in a separate system
for compliance purposes,
or perhaps you want to
keep track of changes
for disaster recovery.
Whatever the reason, the process
to set up a change stream
in Spanner is straightforward.
First, create the change
stream in your database.
A change stream is another
type of object in Spanner,
like a table or a
secondary index.
So you can add, modify, or
delete change stream objects
using DDL.
You can create a
single change stream
for all tables in
a database, or you
can create a change stream
for specific tables or even
specific columns
within those tables.
Second, you need a destination
to receive the changes.
This can be BigQuery, Google
Cloud Storage, Google Pub/Sub,
or any other system to
receive the stream of changes.
And finally, you
set up a pipeline
to process change events from
the change stream and Spanner
and publish to your
downstream system.
You can easily build
data flow pipelines
to process the
change stream events,
leveraging Spanner I/O from
the Apache Beam repository,
or you can connect
directly to the Spanner API
and write your own
processing logic.
This might be best to
explain with an example.
I currently have an inventory
service for an e-commerce store
that is backed by Spanner.
I also have BigQueries set up
to track inventory behavior
over time.
Having this
analytics environment
has enabled me to
make good decisions
on what items to keep in stock.
Currently, to get data
from Spanner into BigQuery,
I had to set up and maintain
additional pipelines
to extract the data in batches
before loading into BigQuery.
These batches cause
some delays that
have caused headaches
for my analysts.
With change streams, I can move
to almost real time streaming
of data changes into
BigQuery and simplify
the logic for processing.
To set up my change stream,
I go into the Cloud Console
page for my Spanner instance.
Then I add my change
stream via the DDL page.
The syntax is fairly
straightforward.
You need a change stream name.
Change stream names are unique
to the Spanner database.
Next, you specify
the entities you want
to track in this change stream.
You can track the entire
database, a set of tables,
or specific columns for tables.
Last, you specify the retention
period for change stream data.
The records that are
tracked are stored
for this retention period before
automatically cleaning up.
By default, the retention
period is 24 hours,
but can range up to 7 days.
And you'll pay only for the
additional storage required
to keep the change
events longer.
Now, I also have my
BigQuery environment set up
that is used for
inventory analytics.
All I have to do is set up the
Dataflow pipeline for BigQuery.
So, I go into Dataflow
in the Cloud Console,
then create a new pipeline.
I provide the pipeline and name.
The region I select
is "us-central1"
to be near my Spanner instance.
And then I select the Cloud
Spanner to BigQuery template.
This template leverages
the Apache Beam Spanner I/O
connector.
Here I need to provide
some more information.
First is the Spanner instance
name and database name.
This is the location
of the change stream
object I created earlier.
Next, I need to provide a
metadata instance and database
name.
This is needed for the
Spanner I/O connector
to keep track of the
changes it has processed.
The metadata
instance and database
can be the same as where the
change stream is located,
but I'd recommend at
least storing the metadata
in its own database.
Once we've provided
the metadata location,
then we provide the
change stream name.
And finally, I specify
a BigQuery data
set to store the data changes.
There are some
optional parameters,
but this is enough
to get started
processing the change
streams from when
the pipeline is created.
That's it.
After a few minutes for
the pipeline to get set up,
I will start receiving
data changes into BigQuery.
As part of releasing
change streams,
the Spanner team has
also released Spanner I/O
to the Apache Beam repository.
Spanner I/O can be used to
process data change events
from Spanner change streams.
There are also three main
Dataflow pipeline templates
available that leverage
Spanner I/O to quickly
get started processing
Spanner change streams.
The first is the
BigQuery template
that I just walked through.
This allows you
to set up BigQuery
to receive changes from
Spanner in near real time.
There is also a Google
Cloud Storage template.
One example of sending data
changes to Cloud Storage
would be to keep an audit
archive of detail change events
on important data for
regulatory purposes.
And finally, there is a
template to publish data changes
to Pub/Sub.
This is useful to
trigger workflows
in external
applications that are
listening on a downstream
Pub/Sub related
to those changes.
If you need to publish data
changes to another destination
or if you need additional
processing of the data changes,
then you can create
a custom pipeline
that leverages the Apache
Beam Spanner I/O connector.
It is also possible to connect
directly to the change stream
API to create a customized
data pipeline without using
the Spanner I/O connector.
It's possible to
have multiple change
streams in the same database
and even multiple change
streams tracking the
same tables or columns.
Here are some things to keep
in mind with multiple change
streams.
You can have up to 10
change streams per database
and up to 3 change streams can
track the same non-key column.
You should maintain no more
than 5 concurrent readers
for a change stream partition
or performance may degrade.
Change streams is a great
new feature in Spanner
that enables real
time data pipelines
based on data changes.
I have shown how to
set up a basic pipeline
to get Spanner data
changes into BigQuery
using the available
Dataflow template.
There are many ways change
streams can be leveraged,
from triggering downstream
application workflows using
Pub/Sub, storing data
within Cloud Storage
to enable data recovery,
or for setting up an audit
trail for compliance purposes.
Let us know in the comments how
you're using change streams,
and if there are other
templates you'd like
us to provide in the future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]